So the branch and jump problems that we have seen
in the previous segment are really due to what is
called a control dependence. Let's say that we have a
program like this. We have an add, then we have
a branch that compares R1 and R3 and jumps to
the label if they are equal. This is the branch
equal. Then we have and add and subtract here, and
we have a multiply here, and they're followed by. Additional instructions.
We say that these instructions have a control dependence on the branch. Whether
these instructions should be executed at all or not depends on the result of
this branch instruction. Similarly, these instructions.
Also have a dependence on the branch.
So pretty much once we have a
branch, all subsequent instructions that we execute
have a control dependence on the branch. This really
means that we don't know whether we should be
even fetching these instructions until we figure out the
branch. So let's see what control dependencies like this
do to the CPI of our five-stage pipeline. On
average, about 20% of all instructions are branches and
jumps. So, about one in five instructions will be
a branch or a jump. We also know that slightly
more than 50% of branch and jump
instructions are what we call taken. Meaning they
go somewhere else and don't just continue.
Putting these two together means that for half
of these instructions we will be fetching the wrong instructions. So our CPI
will be one, this is the ideal CPI, plus 10% of the time we waste some number
of cycles because of a mispredicted branch. Basically we
fetched the wrong instructions. How many cycles we waste? Well,
in our five stage pipeline, if the third stage
is where we figure out the branches, once we do
that, and we determine that we have been wrong
about what we fetched, we have to cancel the two
instructions that we already fetched. So there will be two
cycles of not finishing an instruction. After such a branch,
so what we have is basically every instruction
spins one cycle and 10% of the time
the instruction is followed by two idol cycles,
so the CPI overall will be 1.2 in
this example. If we have a deeper pipeline
that figures out the branches in a later
stage, this penalty for guessing the branch wrong
will be larger. If we have more branches, or
more of them are taken, then this percentage
of instructions that result in this penalty will be
larger. If we are somehow able to guess the
outcomes of branches and fetch the right instructions most
of the time, this percentage here could be
a lot smaller than this. We will see later
a technique called branch prediction that tries to guess
more accurately where the branches are going, and that
dramatically reduces this percentage. We will also
see that modern pipelines tend to be
deeper than just five stages which will
increase this penalty. The two are related
if the pipeline is deeper, and you have more of a penalty. You need better
branch prediction to lower this in order to achieve a CPI that is good.